the thing about Jenny is she's so open
and so honest and I like to think that I
am to Jason Biggs and Jenny Mullin are
staying true to that word sharing a
scary incident involving their son Sid
the couple's five-year-old whose face
they keep private is recovering from a
broken skull which jenni admits happened
because she dropped him on his head by
accident last weekend
the actress shared the story on
Instagram and thanked the hospital staff
for their help she also gave a special
shout-out to her hubby writing thank God
for you thank God thank God
thank God he is my best friend he's the
Apple to my Lucy in a lot of ways you
know he's not desi he goes along with
the caper Jenny called the experienced
quote traumatic but said that Sid is
home now taking things slowly and
recovering nicely she added my heart
goes out to all parents who have or will
ever find themselves in this kind of
position you are not alone Jenny and I
have been honest about our relationship
in our home life so I think that brings
something valuable to the table of
course she brought a little humor to the
caption writing not sure how this post
turned into an Oscars acceptance speech
she's gorgeous and funny the funniest
person I know I laugh all the time with
Jenny Jason and Jenny haven't shied away
from talking about the less than glam
side of having kids and in 2017 when
Jenny was pregnant with their second
child
the couple opened up to et about who is
best under pressure
who is better in an emergency me neither
well you're the daughter of the doctor
so you're my medicine ya know how to
handle you stand out of holiday and
express the other night so you know how
to fix it all I'm just like my whole
life has just been building up to that
moment where I get to go clear the way
I'm a doctor's daughter I can handle
this I'm showing you back together
[Music]